[Music]
[Music]
Wow that was young hilary swank in the
1994 movie the next karate care dealer
he says I was 18 and we were all 18 at
one of at one point her career spans
nearly three decades and she's won two
Academy Awards thank you very much one
for a role as a transgender man and boys
don't cry and the second for playing a
boxer and Million Dollar Baby in the new
movie what they had Hillary Swank plays
a woman caring for her mom who is
suffering from Alzheimer's disease in
this scene Swank's character butts heads
with her father you want to go talk to a
priest I'm not a Catholic anymore
well there's your problem right there
how do you know how do you always know
what my problem is do I do that to you
did I march in here and say she's going
in a hall if you don't like it go talk
to a priest I've listened to you dad I
asked you what you wanted and I fought
like hell to get it for you because you
matter to me what you want matters to me
why hilary swank is also one of the
film's executive producers and joins us
at the table good morning to you Lee so
good to see you too this this movie
feels to me very personal for you
because you've also been in a caretaking
role for your own father who had a lung
transplant yes I what what what we
thought was gonna be a year turned into
three long long years my dad was really
fighting for his life and I was really
thankful that I got the opportunity to
be able to take time off work to care
for him but yeah it very much mirrored
this story in a way having a crisis and
a family and how the family comes
together and it shines a bright light on
the strengths and weaknesses of a family
and on many generations of the family -
that's what we're so cool about this
movie it affects every generation and
you showed us that yeah absolutely and
this movie I feel like it's um you can
relate to it no matter what you have
going on in your life because we've all
dealt with some type of crisis one way
or another and we've had to come
together and try and deal with it and it
deals with family dysfunction but the
love within
the dysfunction well that's right these
acute moments excavate all the history
all the relationship it all just comes
back into one moment yeah and isn't it
crazy no matter how old you get you go
back home and you kind of fall back into
that role that you were when you were
and you're like how is this happening I
said I would hold onto myself this time
but I'm still you know in this case the
character her name is Bridget she's
bitty again and she's like how am I this
you know when I feel like I've evolved
it's just interesting well how's your
father doing
he's great thank you so much he's
healthy he's independent again he's he's
back to his life and so much so that he
was able to walk me down the aisle he
saw that people at Victor I don't we put
it backed up yeah thank you it was a big
big moment
I cried before I even got up to the
altar I was like dad I'm a part of you
were part of getting him there right
being at his side yeah that's what you
do you know he was there for me when I
was a kid it's that's also interesting
how kind of roles reverse yeah what was
that like reversing the roles like I
mean did that hit you or do you start
saying okay they are and now we march
for you're not really thinking about it
when you're in the middle of it until
people ask and talk about it and you
know it's it's obviously it's a big
responsibility you're helping your had
their health advocate and you're helping
them make decisions for what's and best
for them and thankfully it ended up well
but this movie had laughter in the
oddest places because they have a scene
where your mom like Danner whose great
great great in this movie he's beautiful
he's going through Alzheimer's and at
one point she hits on her own son yes
and I'm thinking are we supposed to be
laughing at this yes but those are the
kind of things that happen yeah I think
and crying laughing that's the same side
of the coin isn't it laughter and crying
it's a release and often times I can be
crying and then fall into laughter it's
just they it's it's a release and I
think you have to find levity especially
within circumstances like this wherever
you can and I know Elizabeth's family
that a writer director they deal with
with their crisis like that that picture
that beyond I just said about your dad
walking you down the aisle I am so happy
for you Hillary that you have found love
again did you think that this would
happen to you
well I just reached a point that you
never mind I hoped it would happen
I never got to the place where never
mind but I got to a different place of
searching for it I got to a place of
instead searching for more deeper
meaning inside myself because I had
always been a couple with someone yeah I
was kind of like a always in a
relationship and that's just because you
know I met my ex-husband when I was 18
and I was never I was always with
somebody and so I didn't really know how
to be alone and I think it took me
learning how to be alone learning to
just find and love myself and give to
myself what I was giving to others that
wasn't working instead of trying to make
that work trying to make myself work the
best I could and then then it happened
and I know it sounds cliche but it's
cliché for a reason yeah let me ask you
about acting you came back after a
hiatus is it like riding a bike you just
get back on there you go or was a really
good question I have to say we are so
much what we do right so when people say
Oh tell me about you I usually say well
I'm an actress and then I go out you
know to say other things and so we
realized we're so defined by that so
it's taking time away from that it was
scary but then I realized I'm so much
more than an actress yeah there's all
these other things I was able to explore
about myself and it also gave me a
renewed passion for being an actress I I
think it's we can take things we love
for granted and stepping back in I have
a whole new appreciation for
storytelling whether the best acting
skills come from life lessons so you've
had a very big life the past three years
getting married taking care of your dad
congratulations thank you like in a good
place
yeah like it
what they had isn't sorry brush for time
what they have in select theaters
October 19th